Hey, this is very interesting. There's this
Republican Congressman Dan Crenshaw from Texas.
We've talked about him in the past. He has one
of the most gerrymandered districts I've ever
seen. If you look at the shape of the district,
it's like a crescent moon. It has no basis in
it makes no sense. It's really the prototypical
example of gerrymandering. And Dan Crenshaw is
seen by many on the right as sort
of a different type. Republican,
millennial and more savvy when it comes to social
media and the Internet and sort of some kind of
truthteller and, you know, not like the old guard
Republicans. Well, The Daily Beast now reports
that although Congressman Dan Crenshaw didn't
buy or sell any stocks in his first 13 months
as a congressman in March of twenty twenty one,
the pandemic hit, he made about half a dozen
of the half a dozen buys of stocks and he did not
disclose those right away. He delayed disclosure,
chalking it up to a clerical error. Five of those
purchases came between March 25 and 27. That is
exactly when the Senate and House were voting on
the Keres Act and Trump signed it into law. This
was the first coronavirus stimulus. Crenshaw
supported the bill, didn't disclose his stock
trades in violation of the STOCK Act, which
requires members of Congress to tell the public
when they do any securities trading. Months later,
he amended the records to say, Oh, back in March,
I made these trades and when his office was asked
about it, they said these were clerical errors.
Now, to be clear, Senators Kelly Loffler and
David Perdue were moving millions of dollars in
stock. These trades by Dan Crenshaw. We're talking
about six figures. They add up to no more than one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars. But remember,
Dan Crenshaw has a lot less money than Lefler and
Perdue. But the timing is very, very much suspect.
And it makes us wonder why he made the purchases
and in two series of disclosures, didn't
mention the purchases later did and now says
that it's merely a clerical error and nothing
whatsoever to see here. And what's crazy is
I have done more disclosure of my pandemic
related stock trades than has Dan Crenshaw
or then had Dan Crenshaw in April. In March when
I made the trades. And by the way, I just I just
have a show. I've no reason to disclose anything,
but I do. I came to you guys and I said I made
some stock trades on the basis of the pandemic
Live Nation, which does live events, crashed.
I believe eventually live events will
come back. So I bought Live Nation stock.
I bought Roku stock thinking I've already
owned Netflix for years. I'm not going to
get more Netflix stock. But with people at home, I
think Roku will do really well. Zoome With so many
people working from home, possibly indefinitely
might I said I bought Zoome. I did more disclosure
than Dan Cranshaw did. So is this something, is
it nothing? The point is the guy frames himself
as not like everybody else. This is the new
breed of millennial Republican who's, you know,
different. He is different in that he's not nearly
as wealthy as a lot of these other folks who have
been trading stock. But he seems to be just like
everybody else. And you if you want to know more
about Dan Cranshaw and his antics, check out
some of my other videos, including analyzes of
an appearance he did with Joe Rogan, where he says
some really strange things about socialism and
health care. But when I'm doing more disclosure
than elected officials, you know that something
has gone very, very wrong. And Dan Crenshaw
indistinguishable from these other Republicans.